laissez de côté saphir sa crème
d’épilation ou son rasoir une pratique
défendue par certaines femmes qui
n'hésitent plus à laisser pousser leurs
poils lever les
bras et le 9 février dernier c'est au
tour de la chanteuse Angèle de prendre
position sur ce sujet en partageant une
photo d'elle poil sous les bras
apparents provoquant ainsi de nombreuses
réactions pour rappel ce n'est pas la
première fois que l'artiste belge évoque
le sujet de la pilosité féminine comme
avec cette scène culte qui figure dans
son clip balance ton quoi
Angèle relance le débat enflammé autour
des poils chez les femmes aimez-vous sa
démarche
alors oui oui non alors non bah non je
trouve c'est complètement c'est du
sexisme à l'envers qui est complètement
non constructif elle fait ça pour dire
c'est pas aux hommes de dictée
etc c'est pas une question d'esthétisme
c'est une question de de logique de quoi
comment ça quoi
de beauté de quoi tu parles
elle se réapproprie le son
elle fait ce qu'il y a et pardon pour la
police je l'adore mais c'est vrai que
souvent quand tu as arrêté par une fille
plutôt qu'un mec en général c'est la
fille qui tenait un peu les sacs à main
dans les boîtes de nuit et qui tout d'un
coup à ce qu'on appelle ici avec le
pistolet le symbole phallique elle
devient l'homme et elle a le pouvoir là
c'est une manière de dire des conneries
qu'elle reprend la possession de son
corps au fait qu'elle reprend le pouvoir
oui elle reprend le pouvoir mais elle se
grimpe pas en homme c'est la nature la
nature veut que les femmes
bien compris
si c'est le symbole de de la femme qui
reprend le pouvoir ou mais en fait c'est
très bien bah oui pourquoi il est où le
problème c'est la femme
je trouve ça très bien pour elle moi
personnellement c'est pas mon truc moi
personnellement c'est pas mon truc
mais l'important c'est parce que j'en ai
pas tout simplement mais non une femme
n'a pas de barre mais vous faites une
critère
on se pose la question
non non mais surtout ça sert de
roulement à billes aux endroits où ça
frotte
d'ailleurs quand on sera trop de trop
près trop souvent tu as raison on a des
irritations donc c'est un vrai une vraie
utilité
[Applaudissements]
trouve surtout que c'est génial j'aurais
adoré qui Angèle quand j'étais
adolescente parce que ça a été un drame
moi j'avais des poils sur les jambes je
n'arrivais pas à les enlever j'étais en
j'étais sur la
vie il est sensible
c'était un vrai drame et je suis pas
question
sur la plage tellement j'étais complexée
donc j'aurais adoré avoir un gel qui
m'attendais
j'ai trouvé un système mais j'ai mis
longtemps avant de trouver le système et
c'était horrible on est plus ou moins
poilus je suis désolé et ça a été le
drame
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouvre la boîte de Pandore
[Rires]
Duba
mais non c'était l'adolescence mais en
revanche on peut être libre de garder ça
et puis comme ça c'est important c'est
un bon discours c'est important d'avoir
des poils oui mais après moi j'adore
Angèle militante féministe je la trouve
formidable mais c'est vrai que rien rien
neuf sous les selles parce que ça ce
genre de combat on l'a déjà dit mille
fois par des artistes par des chanteuses
par des militantes donc c'est pas là
c'est un peu une posture et moi je suis
d'accord et Valérie a raison et donc
excuse-moi Mathieu tu ne comprends rien
et Jean-Mi non plus parce que vous êtes
des vieux hétéros et vieille homo en
fait
encore très beau bien sûr parce que je
veux dire
quand on se rase les poils quand on est
fan c'est une injonction de l'homme
c'est-à-dire que la femme de poils parce
que dans la pornographie la femme doit
avoir le sexe comme un bidet et ne pas
avoir de poils nulle part voilà parce
que c'est comme ça et sauf que les
femmes
est-ce qu'il y a des fois
au milieu de la au milieu de la touffe
et tout voilà un homme reste un homme
arrêtez de faire des hommes
reste une femme donc une femme qui
aurait des poils n'est pas une femme
une femme a des injonctions des choses à
faire non
à quoi ressemblait une femme une femme
juste qui serait nature elle serait
comme ça
excuse-moi est-ce que vous cliquez le
persil qui sort du Cabaye
bien sûr
ne trouve ça beau vous dites juste que
c'est beau parce que c'est Angèle non
parce que c'est Angèle et quand j'ai des
trucs très belles femmes c'était tissu
une femme lambda vous trouverez ça très
moche donc arrêtez et puis si elle se
veut pas se plier au dicte de la mode à
ce moment-là qu'elle se qu'elle se
maquille jamais qu'elle prenne notre
kilos
casserait
qui sort du caddie
Géraldine tu es aussi populaire
tu la vois plus je suis obligé de
souffler dessus pour dire regarde ma
[__]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
par contre toi
j'adore
ça me rappelle le 8 mars avec Daniel
[Applaudissements]
j'adore
toucher toute la journée malheureusement
c'est je les ai pas mais je vais voir
la sodomie
je viens juste de revenir
[__]
Jean-Michel viens
tu vas tu vas tu vas faire
ça des dictats moi j'appelle ça ce monde
des efforts que les hommes et les femmes
font des efforts
ne pense pas du tout comme toi
et les femmes se laissent aller nous
aussi
ça choquent sont des hommes pas du tout
donc et vous voulez lui dire et vous
venez nous dire qu'il y a pas de dicta
hein
pourquoi question est-ce que vous votre
compagne à la batavia qui sort du sapin
c'est à moi que vous me demandez
[Rires]
[Musique]